it seems like a new Nintendo switch game  gets announced every day I'm Tony and  this GameSpot news update is all about  RPGs Dragon Quest 11 was already slated  for ps4 and 3ds and now we know it's  also coming to the switch this news  comes on top of Dragon Quest 10 also  being planned for Nintendo's new console  the latest trailer doesn't reveal too  much of the game but you should probably  expect that classic dragon quest vibe  there's also no solid release date but  it's currently plans for 2017 at least  for the ps4 and 3ds versions speaking of  Nintendo you can check out GameSpot's  top 5 Wii U games of 2016 right now and  tune into our game of the year  livestream on Tuesday December 20th at  10 a.m. Pacific we'll have all sorts of  special guests and prizes for you there  for all the latest Nintendo news you're  already in the right place